[Musique]
c'est jour de livraison chemli dignity
depuis trois ans l'organisme offre des
produits menstruel à celles qui en ont
besoin
ces boîtes livrons à des étudiants de la
commission scolaire english montreal la
monstration c'est un phénomène
biologique inévitable qui affecterait de
50% de la population
mais les prix de ces produits sont
excessifs pour celles qui vivent en
situation de précarité pour des femmes
sans abri par exemple pour celles qui se
retrouvent sans emploi ou bien pour des
étudiantes qui ont un budget serré le
constat de l'organisme la précarité
menstruel touche plus de femmes qu'on le
pense
c'était resté un problème caché la
précarité menstruel parce que ça c'est
créer une jonction de sujets tabous pour
défaire c'est tabou le réseau québécois
d'action pour la santé des femmes a
lancé sa campagne rouge l'année dernière
sur le terrain la précarité menstruel
est bien visible
on a des histoires des témoignages ou
les femmes plis du papier journal
elle utilise où elle découpe des
bouteilles en plastique et il utilisa
comme des coupes menstruelles products
le parlement écossais a décidé de
s'attaquer au problème
en novembre les élus ont adopté à
l'unanimité loi pour rendre les produits
d'hygiène féminine gratuit ya celles qui
en ont besoin
une première dans le monde qui a suscité
l'intérêt ici c'est la valeur symbolique
en fait de cette action-là qui pose
parce que ça montre une volonté
politique et du moment qu'on a une dont
on peut on peut le faire et on peut on
peut agir ça nous en inspirer justement
à solliciter le gouvernement
oui c'est un problème des femmes mais
c'est parce que c'est un problème
seulement des femmes qui est un problème
auquel on devrait peut s'adresser
montrent les derniers tic compte bientôt
frapper à la porte du gouvernement
fédéral
d'ailleurs des initiatives existent déjà
au pays la colombie britannique et la
nouvelle écosse offre ses produits
gratuitement dans les écoles ici qui me
permettra au canada montréal